[Music]
so
[Music]
hello my name is cecil slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songs from testimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slupovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ischenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii several songs that we are presenting
here
were actually the beginning of this
music project carried out
by the archive and they all came from
lube of kay's testimony uh
libov k was born and raised and lived
her life
in zvenigarotka in ukraine and she ended
up
with many of her fellow citizens
in a slave labor camp suffering
hunger cold tortures
loss of family friends
and homes two of her
four songs that she presented did not
have
any music she recited them as poems
so i took liberty to write music to
those
poems in the style that would be
adequate and representative
of the music popular at the time in
eastern europe and in the soviet union
in ukraine possibly and
this song that tells the story of
stephan
the ukrainian collaborationist guard
an extremely cruel person
i use the genres of tango which was a
very young genre at the time and
military march i sometimes turned to
military feel there
stupid
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
already
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes
[Music]
a month after liberoff k and her fellow
prisoners were taken from the vinegar
ghetto to the neymar's labor camp north
of the city
conditions in the camp became so crowded
that the german authorities decided to
split the camp
in two lubuf and half of the neymar's
prisoners were transferred to milchensen
a village approximately 12 kilometers
northwest of nyamarosh
later that year on november 2nd 1942
the german gendarmeri liquidated the
neymar's camp
executing all of the prisoners who
remained there
nubof k and the other prisoners who had
been transferred to smilshensei
remained there until december 1942
when they were transferred yet again
this time to buddhism
a village eight kilometers northeast of
snoochinsa
conditions in buddhism were somewhat
better than in nyamrash and smilchensei
for two main reasons first the prisoners
were housed in a village clubhouse
rather than in barns as lebroff calls
quote the building wasn't heated but the
floor was
wooden instead of dirt and at least it
was an enclosed space
end quote second the villagers of
buddhist
and the nearby village of shisterinse
were remarkably generous
towards the labour camp prisoners dubois
recalls
quote they were wonderful people all we
can do is say thank you to them for the
rest of our lives
of course we would like to express our
gratitude to them somehow
they would come to the camp they would
persuade the pulitzei
bring us half liters bring us pieces of
bread
a potato here and there and if they
lived nearby
something hot to eat they really
supported us
end quote as time went on the prisoners
themselves became more daring
on their way back to the camp after a
hard day's labor on the transit highway
4
project they would run in pairs into the
village to beg for something to eat
it was one such foray into a neighboring
village
that inspired the song stephane as
lebron calls
in general the ukrainian auxiliary
police who guarded the camp
would turn a blind eye to the prisoners
brief absences
as dubois puts it quote the police
pulitzei had been with
us so long they knew that we wouldn't
run away
end quote while these temporary absences
could be overlooked
any actual escape would entail severe
consequences for the remaining prisoners
in the camp
the german overseers had a rule that if
one prisoner ran away from the camp
10 innocent prisoners would be shot this
threat
proved to be a strong deterrent against
any plans of escape
as the wolf puts it quote we didn't want
to be the cause of others death
we decided that whatever happened it
would happen to all of us together
end quote so despite the guard's
generally permissive attitude towards
temporary absences on one unfortunate
sunday
new wolf and nine other prisoners snuck
out to the village during a roll call
the blonde guard stephan met them at the
gate as they returned
demanding to know where they had been
the prisoners apologized profusely and
promised not to venture out again
much to their surprise stephan didn't
punish anyone
immediately instead he waited until the
following day
monday during that morning's roll call
he demanded
the ten of you step forward while
everyone else was taken out
to work in the forest that day stephan
took
his ten unfortunate prisoners to lusinco
the group was fully convinced that they
were being taken to the gendarmerie to
be shot
but instead stephan took them to the
highway department
in leesenka where the director and
foreman of the highway department worked
there they were greeted by a young mean
german by the name of hans
hans ordered stephan to give them each
20 lashes with a ramrod and that is
exactly what stephan did
the following day tuesday lubov
and the other nine prisoners ate their
usual breakfast of watery gruel
and then one by one stephan and one
other guard
gave them each 25 lashes with a ramrod
in the kitchen as dubois recalls
quote we crawled out of the kitchen on
all fours
and after that beating we went back to
work
end quote to immortalize this agonizing
experience the prisoners wrote a song
describing the brutality of handsome yet
heartless dupont like the other three
songs that lubov shares in her testimony
this ode to stephan was composed
collectively by the prisoners
as you both explains quote everyone
wrote the songs
all together this one would give a word
that one would give two
this one a line and the next would add
another that's how it came together for
us
while the lyrics of this song describe
their ordeal in unflinchingly factual
terms
in a certain sense by writing this song
the prisoners were able to have the last
laugh at stupan's expense
he tried to break their will and yet
they still had the power to compose a
song
about their blonde tormentor because
songs like these were not committed to
paper but instead were memorized
if even one of the camp inmates survived
their collective history would survive
as well
along with the identity of their
tormentors
while dubois does not shy away from
describing the cruelty of ukrainian
collaborators like stephan
her testimony also pays grateful tribute
to the local ukrainian villagers
who brought food to lupoif and her
fellow prisoners while they were in
the buddhist [ __ ] labor camp complex
accounts of collaboration
and compassion are just one of the
aspects that make
survivor testimonies likely woofs
completely invaluable in preserving the
history of the holocaust
[Music]
so
[Music]